dude pull that gun put it down pull it
down dude put it down an Oklahoma police
officer is shot and injured when a
suspect rushes at him removes his gun
from The holster and opens fire put it
down dude pull that gun get away from me
put it down put it down get away from me
the incident happened on March 13th in
Oklahoma City Oklahoma police were
called to the Oklahoma County Crisis
Intervention center after reports of a
Man attacking people inside with a large
metal three-hole punch the man was later
identified as 19 year old Christian
green body camera video shows the first
responding officer Seth Maxwell
repeatedly asked green to relax and put
down the three hole punch relax dude
what's going on
put that down
hey put it down
hey
put that down Green can be heard on the
video saying he wants to die
hey put that down hey put it down dude
put it down
put it down dude it's then that green
calls for officer Maxwell to take out
his weapon pull it down dude put it down
police say green refused to put down the
three hole punch and would not comply
with officers when they attempted to
take him into custody a struggle broke
out put it down dude pull that gun get
away from me put it down put it down get
away from me body camera video captures
the moment officer Maxwell is shot
officials say green reached for his
holstered weapon and fired after that
green is taken into custody officer
Maxwell can be heard saying he isn't
sure if he's okay
what about that
[Music]
where you at
oh you all right I don't know Green was
booked into the Oklahoma County
Detention Center and now thesis charges
of a sultan battery and assault with a
deadly weapon the Oklahoma City Police
Department says Maxwell was injured and
taken to the hospital to be treated he's
since recovered and has returned to work
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie